[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver à
la une de ça vous regarde ce soir
emmanuel macron à l'épreuve de la
détestation de la tentative d'intrusion
dans un théâtre parisien alain 110 son
restaurant favori la personne du chef de
l'état est la cible de toutes les
manifestations alors pourquoi emmanuel
macron suscite il tant de haine est ce
que cette violence est inédite dans le
pays ses prédécesseurs ont-ils essuyé
une telle défiance on en parle ce soir
dans notre grand débat la mobilisation
contre la réforme des retraites prend
elle aussi un tournant radical la cgt
énergie revendique des coupures géante
d'électricité le siège de la cfdt a fait
l'objet de deux intrusions en à peine
quelques jours comment éviter un
durcissement du conflit
nous poserons la question à l'europe et
rachesky et le nouveau monsieur
retraites du gouvernement est notre
invité et puis notre grand témoin ce
soir est un lève tôt et un couche tard
il court il court pour être au rendez
vous de ces nombreuses vies journaliste
écrivain et comédien christophe barbier
est avec nous ce soir voilà donc pour le
programme c'est parti hashed accédèrent
n'oubliez pas on y va
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
nos invités en plateau ce soir
christophe barbier bonsoir joie merci
d'être notre grand témoin éditorialiste
à l'express hebdomadaire que vous avez
longtemps dirigé à bfm tv le matin et
sur les planches le soir on en parlera
vous publié aux édition de
l'observatoire macron sous les masques
de qui le président est-il le fils et
c'est un peu à la manière d'un jeu et si
c'était un personnage historique un
philosophe une figure mythologique que
vous au fond en fait cette enquête
généalogique sur le président de la
république on en parlera un peu plus
tard dans l'émission mais d'abord on va
revenir sur ces scènes de violences
auxquelles nous assistons depuis
quelques semaines quelques jours at on
franchit un cran supplémentaire nicolas
sarkozy l'ex chef de l'état est sorti de
sa réserve pour se tirer la sonnette
d'alarmé
on en parle avec vous ce soir bruno
keitel bonsoir vous êtes député la
république en marche de leur roland
cayrol bienvenue sur ce plateau
politologue directeur de recherche au
cevipof spécialiste de l'opinion
macron sur la corde raide c'est votre
dernier ouvrage ça tombe bien pour notre
débat c'était chez calmann-lévy boris
balle au bond soir je dis merci d'être
là député socialiste des landes et
richard wehrli éditorialistes maison ici
dans cette émission à ça vous regarde et
le correspondant aux parisiens du
quotidien suisse le temps voilà pour les
présentations vous le savez celui qui
inaugure comme chaque soir cette
émission qui nous plante le décor à sa
manière c'est stéphane stéphane
blakowski si j'ai bien compris tout de
suite
[Musique]
bon sans myriam bonsoir monsieur fait
installer vous alors c'est de ne pas
rater le tobogan petit tabouret veut
dire beaucoup d'invités mérité le siège
contre on vous a bien compris cette fois
alors si j'ai bien compris mais regarde
il ya quand même une montée de la
contestation contre mâcon qui ce qui se
radicalise alors on se demande pourquoi
tant de haine parce que après tout quand
même le chômage est au plus bas depuis
10 ans les investisseurs étrangers se
précipitent en france l'an dernier on
n'a jamais créé autant d'entreprises
confrontés toute cette économie qui se
redresse bon feeling ça annonce une
forme de prospérité à venir et donc
bresse attendent que les français
célèbrent l'argent du président voir
l'ue organise une petite fête pour le
remercier de tous ces bons résultats
économiques fait et en fait c'est
curieux mais s'est pas du tout passé
comme savoir alors ne dramatisons pas
non plus quand même pas si grave parce
qu'en décembre on a fait la moyenne des
baromètres de popularité pour macro il
est à 24 % donc deux points au dessus de
hollande
au même moment de son mandat donc c'est
quand même pas si grave est quand même
différent ce que les gens qui n'aimaient
pas hollande le méprisait ce qui faisait
rien alors que les gens qui l'aiment pas
macron il le déteste il le haïssent sans
doute parce qu'il fait beaucoup trop de
trucs donc du coup il ya deux hypothèses
à mon avis un soin ces macro qui a un
tempérament qui fait qu' il excite les
français comme dirait jean michel
apathie ou alors ou alors une montée de
la violence en france
elles se cristallisent sur macron le
pauvre je vais dire qu'il n'y est pour
rien si ce n'est qu'il est président des
banques qui l'attirent la colère sur lui
alors qu'elle est la meilleure hypothèse
selon vous le pensez bien que je veux
certainement pas mouillé dans cette
histoire mais ça dépend du point de vue
moral dans lequel on considère situation
du point de vue la position est
évidemment tenté de dire que c'était un
peu la faute de macron alors bien sûr
s'agit certainement pas de soutenir la
violence personne ne dit que on a bien
fait de vouloir s'en prendre un
maquereau dans une salle de théâtre mais
marine le pen par exemple est ce parce
qu'elle est avocate qu'elle plaide les
circonstances atténuantes par des
formations professionnelles je ne sais
pas en tout cas elle dit bah oui mais
les gens qui sont recours à la violence
il faut les comprendre c'est un peu de
la faute du gouvernement il faut bien
dire que le gouvernement par son
comportement a contribué au fur et à
mesure du temps à cette montée en
tension même si ça n'excuse pas encore
une fois les agissions auquel
on a assisté hier ou avant-hier jean luc
mélenchon
quelle est sa position ben c'est pas si
différent de celle de marine le pen y
cultive un petit peu la même l'ambiguïté
donc pas de sonore vous montre juste un
tweet vous allez voir dans le même temps
huit des phrases qui paraissent un peu
contradictoires d'un côté il est
d'accord avec les français qui disent
qu'il faut que ça pète pour demont et en
même temps et d'image avaient eu recours
à la violence
donc l'insurrection sans violence on
paraît pas très crédible donc il ya un
truc lagon et en même temps il faut les
comprendre et mélenchon et le pen c'est
un deux candidats qui ont obtenu 40% des
voix à eux deux au premier tour
aujourd'hui l'assemblée ils ont 4 % des
sièges donc comme ils n'ont pas moyens
de peser sur le débat à l'assemblée
bhp la moindre des choses pour eux ça se
comprend c'est d au moins de 2 des sites
s'appuient sur la colère qui se
manifestent dans la rue donc que le
président n'est pas la seule cible dans
cette violence en ligne la montée de la
violence politique en france donc au
l'an dernier les gilet jaune qui défonce
et les ministères entre autres pendant
toute l'année on a eu donc les
permanences attaqué des maisons
incendiées comme pour les députés de la
république en marche et puis que le
récemment c'était la cfdt où il ya eu un
un commando on va dire une équipe de cgt
énergie qui est venu leur couper le
courant autoritairement pendant pendant
une bonne alors philippe martinez et là
il a condamné alors
alors on a justement dont on dit parfois
martinez manque de nuance
détrompez-vous il fait preuve d une
grande nuance il n'a pas grande année
justement il est dit qu'il ne
cautionnait pas c'est pas exactement la
même chose veiller en fait si on
additionne au bout du compte tous les
mécontents ceux qui soutiennent le pen
ceux qui soutiennent mélenchon ceux qui
sont derrière les syndicats
contestataires
ça permet un bon paquet de français qui
pensent que la violence est un recours
légitime aujourd'hui ça me rappelle un
sondage dans l'atlantique au mois de mai
2010 9 39% des français pensent
qu'aujourd'hui la meilleure solution
pour que ça change en france c'est la
révolution
alors face à la colère qui gronde on est
où là c'est une révolte c'est une
révolution cyr là quelqu'un s'est porté
au secours du président de la république
c'est justement un ancien président de
la république en écoute je peux pas
accepter ce spectacle là parce qu'ils
abaissent notre pays et moi je n'aime
qu'une chose c'est ce qui valorise la
france et ses scènes de violence elle
abaisse la france
et ben voilà on arrive à l'heure du
débat c'est à dire est ce que c'est la
violence de ces contestations abaisse la
france comme dit sarkozy ou est-ce que
la violence de ces contestation secoue
la france pour lui permettre de trouver
un régime meilleur peut-être même des
lendemains qui chantent
je sais pas quelque chose de mieux faire
face vaste sujet cette question va
reprendre peut-être point par point
merci stéphane bruno questel déjà sur la
violence qui s'exerce à l'encontre
d'emmanuel maquereau ou de la fonction
présidentielle qui l'incarnent vous
allez nous dire qu'elle est quel est
votre choix parce qu'on se pose la
question est-ce que c'est sa personne
ou est-ce que c'est sa fonction qui est
visé elle est plus préoccupante que
d'autres violences qu'ont pu subir ses
prédécesseurs elle et s'il n'était pas
en fonction ils subiraient moins de
violence et donc je crois qu'il faut il
faut pas chercher à dissocier les deux
aujourd'hui maintenant la société
énormément évolué ces dernières années
on est depuis dix huit 18 20 mois dans
un climat de violence il faut pas le
nier et on est aussi dans une des
plaques bougent encore dans notre pays
on voit des dissensions entre les
syndicats et la violence que ça génère
on voit le des conséquences non encore
achevée du big bang politique qui s'est
produit en 2017 et on est une question
qu'on doit poser un moment il vous
l'avez fait dans votre conclusion
c'est celle de la nature du régime et
des institutions si on pose pas la
question sur sion mais pas sur la table
la question de la nature des
institutions du rapport à la citoyenneté
à la république de la responsabilité
individuelle et collective
on ne sortira pas de l'ornière la
notaire des institutions c'est
qu'aujourd'hui la rose non c'est pas ça
que je veux dire je veux dire juste que
les institutions telle qu'elle
fonctionne aujourd'hui le citoyen ne s'y
retrouvent pas citic nous citoyens de
manière sereine sont pas dans l'urgence
ou dos au mur ou dans la violence pour
que justement ça a commencé avec ce qui
s'est passé au sérieux avec les 150
personnes qui a au sort pour justement
participé à l'élaboration d'une
politique environnementale qui nous
seront proposés la démocratie
représentative n'est plus assez
représentative
je dis qu'il faut poser le sujet sur la
table pour voir de quelle manière
faire en sorte que les citoyens de ce
pays ne se sent pas écartée dans
l'intervalle des scrutins dassin aux 6 8
10 la proportionnelle est aussi un autre
précise la proportionnelle nous
nous demandons qu'à la mettre en oeuvre
mais je rappellerai juste que c'est pas
nous qui le conduit le processus
on va revenir sur le diagnostic roland
cayrol vous diriez qu'elle est inédite
cette violence déjà sur la personne du
président de la république
non d'abord eu un entend beaucoup
d'expressions adoma d'abord la france
direction séditieux français pas feu et
à sang on est nous vivons quand même une
période historique où qui est la moins
violente de votre histoire
les meurtres les assassinats les
infanticides
les viols intrafamiliaux tout ça que
celui des courbes extrêmement
descendante
on vit de plus en plus dans une société
qui règle ces conflit par la négociation
et par le droit
ce qui est plutôt un signe de
civilisation et de calme progressif
alors en revanche il ya des acteurs
sociaux et singulièrement les acteurs
politiques qui n'arriveront pas à se
faire entendre notamment pour les
raisons que mon voisin viennent dire ont
besoin d'avoir des actions telles que
les médias et les réseaux sociaux mais
retiennent et pour être à l'ordre du
jour des médias notamment ceux de
l'information continue et des réseaux
sociaux il faut faire des coups d'éclat
et il faut parler violent ça c'est un
envahissement en effet progressif
alors je dirais pas tellement sur le
président de la république on a connu la
même chose pour tous
l'expression président des riches n'a
pas été inventé pour macron mais pour
sarkozy
rappelez-vous les deux dernières années
du mandat de sarkozy quand il allait en
province comme on disait à l'époque
région comme on dirait maintenant dans
la région elle voir tout à l'heure dans
un d'en avoir dans les territoires tout
était bloqué et c'était super sous
contrôle
la vidéosurveillance est gendarmerie
françois hollande nous et plus aller au
restaurant parce qu'ils avaient peur
d'être sifflé partout il arrivait lancé
on est dans une société tellement devenu
aseptisé et attentive à la violence que
il suffit que une vingtaine ou une
trentaine de types a et crier dans un
théâtre pour que ça paraisse ils
n'attendront joue à se faire peur
on joue un peu à se faire peur oui
maurice ballot je vous reprends la
phrase quand même de nicolas sarkozy une
de ses nombreuses phrases donc c'était
hier
lors des voeux des républicains
l'indifférence la haine de l'autre
l'abstention est l'anti parlementarisme
ce sont les quatre cavaliers de
l'apocalypse en france ça va loin quand
même c'est ça qui nous qui nous guette
est ce qu'on peut dire d'abord c'est que
la violence politique
en effet elle n'est pas d'une radicale
nouveauté qu'elle s'exprime aujourd'hui
en revanche elle est peut-être dans une
société policée et c'est heureux bien
moins tolérées qu'elle a pu l'être par
le passé ce n'est pas un mode de
régulation des conflits et la violence
et ça je crois que c'est clair dans un
régime démocratique donc elle n'a jamais
excusable pour nom mais elle n'est
jamais allée réflexe que jamais notez
bien que beaucoup de gens qui ont de
l'exécration du ressentiment des
désaccords avec le président de la
république et sa politique de le
manifeste autrement que par de la
violence et je crois qu'ils sont très
très majoritaire là où je voudrais
rejoindre mon collègue parlementaire
c'est que en effet on a un problème
institutionnel grave on a une cinquième
république est à bout de souffle et des
institutions qui sont pathologiquement
incapable de créer du débat du compromis
ça c'est une chose et qu'ils appellent
une réforme des institutions pas dans le
sens de ce qui à mon avis était proposée
par le président de la république qui ne
rééquilibre est pas les pouvoirs qui ne
donnaient pas plus de prérogatives au
parlement de capacités aux oppositions à
se faire entendre
évidemment cela mais il ya aussi une
pratique institutionnelle pratique
politique depuis deux ans et demi qui
est propre au président de la république
qui est à dire de d'avilissement du
débat du débat parlementaire
d'avilissement d'une diète du dialogue
social en effet leur position et
finalement quand on se retrouve ya plus
de place pour l'opposition health
extrêmement la rue mais regardez quel a
été le discours du président de la
république au congrès dès juillet 2010
est toute opposition était un refus de
regarder le monde en face tout désaccord
et et de la basse politique quand on
n'est pas avec emmanuel macron on est
contre la france ça réduit évidemment
beaucoup l'espace de débat et de
fabrique du compromis et si nous en
sommes là je parle pas des violences je
parle de 2,2 du climat dans ce dans ce
dans ce pays c'est que la vitalité
démocratique a jamais été aussi aussi
faible alors je vous donne la parole
vous allez répondre une enquête elle
mais christophe barbier votre regard
il a une part de responsabilité mais non
macron dans cette violence qu'il suscite
oui une part de responsabilité pour une
bonne et une mauvaise chose la bonne
chose quand même c'est que c'est un
président qui lancent beaucoup de
réformes qui veut changer
structurellement le pays
alors évidemment ça crée des séismes et
il ya des tas de réaction il ya des
réactions de conservatisme d'archaïsme
il y aurait des réactions aussi de gens
qui sont dans l'affolement dans la
panique face à ce monde nouveau qui
s'ouvre et pour lequel ne se sentent pas
armés mais peut-on reprocher un
président de vouloir faire rattraper du
retard un pays qui a une mauvaise raison
c'est une inadéquation entre sans son
mode d'incarnation de la présidence au
début fameux jupiter est une société qui
avait besoin d'être un peu plus cajoler
un peu plus accompagner la france les
français ont voulu un président qui
n'est pas eu de mandat avant qu'il n'ait
pas eu de passif mais il pouvait pas
avoir en même temps un président qui
connaissent toutes les subtilités des
territoires vous ne les dossiers y a pas
de quoi s'inquiéter tant que ça parce
que marlène schiappa qui est pas d'un
climat séditieux c'est quand même fort
que moi là je partage l'avis de roland
nous n'oublions pas qu'on a tiré sur le
général de gaulle était donc un climat
de violence et sur jacques chirac
on a eu des climats violence plus fort
et puis tu n'as qu'à nicolas sarkozy
notre pays est passé par des phases
révolutionnaire des phases de quasi
guerre civile bien plus intense nous
sommes maintenant un vieux pays qui
n'accepte plus les révolutions parce que
l'évolution c'est des barricades c'est
du sang on en veut plus et tant mieux on
a fait un progrès dans l'humanisme
mais on voudrait des changements
radicaux comment faire et changement
sans avoir le grand basculement legrand
bousculement et puis enfin on a un
problème de démocratie représentative ça
a été évoqué et dans ce problème là il y
a le rejet le refus de la légitimité de
la violence accordé jadis à l'état
on supporte plus qu'il y ait des morts
il ya 150 ans notre dame des landes ça
ce serait réglé par des régimes en
dégageant la zone y aurait eu cent
cinquante morts mais tout le monde redit
mais c'est comme ça aujourd'hui c'est
plus possible c'est tant mieux
heureusement qu'on le fait que j'ai lu
un édito d'eric le boucher à vos
confrères puisqu'il ya plusieurs
journalistes sur ce plateau qui explique
dans l'opinion emmanuel macron fait
l'objet d'une haine viscérale désormais
déchaîné extrêmement préoccupante car
susceptible d'enfanter ça va vous
intéresser c'est une référence
historique un ravaillac l'assassin 24
dans les gilet jaune
on a pendu en effigie on a des capitaux
réfugiés emmanuel macron il ya aussi le
phénomène des réseaux sociaux qui fait
que ce genre de simulacre prennent une
puissance alors qu'avant personne ne les
voyez quelque chose aussi que je crois
qu'il faut pas occulter celle incarnée
si on de la fonction est ce que emmanuel
macron s'est passé en chef
j'avais rappelez vous la manière dont il
l'a congédié le général de villiers avec
une autorité non dissimulé nicolas
sarkozy s'était placé en chef avec une
autre méthode notamment dans la relation
avec le premier ministre et françois
hollande était pas tout à fait dans
cette posture ou dans cette position et
à tel point qu'il n'incarnait plus la
fonction à la fin la preuve il a pas
plus représentés mais mais mais sur le
fond je crois qu'on a on a affaire aussi
à des débordements chez nous quand je
vois un collègue qui vient devant
l'elysée faire un parallèle entre
emmanuel macron et le président kennedy
je me dis que le collègue est sorti des
clous parce que le collègue sait aussi
qu'il va être regardé qui va être vu sur
les sur les réseaux sociaux et qu'il
peut générer effectivement ravaillac ou
autre ou quelqu'un qui partirait en live
et ça c'est ça c'est terriblement de
france arf un jeu de l'opacité dans le
temps les derniers ont selon lui deux
points parmi ses électeurs je vais pour
ma banque ça a commencé ils avaient
leçon c'est ce qu'ils disent puis ils
ont vérifié au fond images à l'appui au
fond ce consensus sur ce plateau au fond
c'est pas pire cuillère si je puis dire
éléments de réponse en image avec ce
sujet de hélène bonduelle des
manifestants qui tentent de pénétrer
dans le théâtre où le président de la
république assiste à une représentation
emmanuel macron pris pour cible au puy
en velay en plein conflit des gilet
jaune il ya un an
autant de séquences désastreuse pour
l'image du président mais cette
hostilité et elle spécifie coprésidents
macron il ya un facteur nouveau qui est
l'impact croissant et de l'information
continue et des réseaux sociaux c'est à
dire de l'exposition permanente et
intrusive de n'importe quel chef d'état
et ça n'est pas un hasard si ça a frappé
successivement pour des raisons
différentes parce que leurs styles très
différents mais nicolas sarkozy françois
hollande et maintenant emmanuel macron
il ya il ya un chaudron de colère de
calomnies de fantasmes qui est permanent
et dans lequel ils sont tous obligés de
tomber nicolas sarkozy déjà avait fait
face à la défiance dès son élection la
victoire au fouquet's les vacances sur
le yacht de son ami vincent bolloré ne
passe pas quelques mois plus tard il est
bousculé par des marins pêcheurs sur le
port du guilvinec vous parler comme ça
je ne vous parle pas un coaching son
successeur françois hollande fait lui
aussi les frais de la détestation
ambiante
les opposants au mariage pour tous les
adversaires de la réforme du code du
travail
chaque déplacement devient mouvementée
[Applaudissements]
mais les conditions de l'accession au
pouvoir des manuels matheron sa
personnalité aussi pourrait selon ce
spécialiste de la politique expliquer
cette haine
sur le plan politique c'est s'éteint
c'est un novice et qui accumule des
erreurs mais qui sont des erreurs - des
erreurs de fond des erreurs de
techniques et d'expression du prononce
des petites phrases intempestives on le
sait tous et il ya un côté un peu
irrépressible à politique expérimenté
c'est un politique qui arrive justement
à surmonter ce qui est irrépressible
alors emmanuel macron peut-il se
réconcilier avec les français les plus
hostiles et reconquérir ceux qui doutent
il a dit qu'il allait et j'ajoute de mon
point de vue enfin faire une émission
pour expliquer ce que c'est que sa
réforme des retraites si l'occasion de
cette émission il arrive à être
convaincant à l'issue d'un conflit qu'il
n'aura pas perdu à ce moment là il peut
retrouver comme après le grand débat une
partie de ceux qui ont potentiellement
confiance dans ce qu'il peut incarner si
certains proches du chef de l'état ne
cachent pas leur inquiétude c'est toute
la classe politique qui est sceptique
ah ça va être difficile à beaucoup
d'efforts à faire pour se réconcilier
avec les français mais si il voulait le
faire
la première chose qu'il faudrait faire
c'est retirer ce projet de loi et ouvrir
une véritable discussion s'il veut à mon
avis retrouver le fil des français il
faut que l'europe qui leur montre un
horizon est pas jouer le rôle uniquement
du réformateur
il restera deux ans avant la prochaine
élection présidentielle pour se
réconcilier avec les français
il n'arrivera pas se réconcilie avec
tous les français parce qu'il ya
aujourd'hui des français qui sont très
très en colère
prochaine journée test vendredi jour de
présentation de la réforme des retraites
en conseil des ministres n'avait pas
l'air d'accord
regardons ce sujet non mais je trouve
que d'abord eu beaucoup d'indulgence
d'un jeune président non il est
président de la république avec les
responsabilités qui vont avec beaucoup
de préciser aussi dans une vidéo
finalement ça bouscule pas ce qui
réforme la réforme mais pas une fin en
soi
d'ailleurs parce que c'est une jeune
formation politique qui n'a pas de
culture politique de référentiel
historique en font souvent la
liquidation et la réforme est parfois un
certain nombre de
rencontre premier républicain qui ont
survécu aux alternances sont ébranlés
sans même que l'exécutif on est
conscient c'est d'ailleurs on voit dans
l'hémicycle parfois d arc républicain
des gaullistes sociaux jusqu'à la gauche
sans s'en émouvoir si si il y à cette
mécontentement des français c'est pour
des questions c'est pour des questions
c'est pour des questions de fond par le
culte de deux cultures des lectures je
pensais que le monde est avec vous donc
c'est plus ça c'est les français on
global année bien compris qu'elles sont
les ateliers dont la république tchèque
est un libéral est par ailleurs il ya la
façon d'être du président de la
république il s'est fait élire sur la
promesse d'écouter tout le monde de
prendre les meilleures idées des uns et
des autres il a fini par écouter que de
lui même et les sols aujourd'hui il est
seul
ono keitel la solitude d'un président
qui au fond a fait non mais à braser le
paysage politique aussi un délai tester
y rester des électeurs de droite
non mais le président de la république
les conditions de son élection ils sont
aussi liées aux conditions d'exercice du
mandat précédent je suis désolé vous
avez succédé à emmanuel macron à
l'elysée non les fonctions de secrétaire
général adjoint
on n'a pas senti de bouleversements de
politique entre le moment où il était en
fonction et le moment où vous avez pris
ce même poste ça veut dire quand même
qu'il ya une forme de continuité et donc
il ya aussi les missions qu'ils mentent
pas ils étaient heureux de remonter
celles aujourd'hui on est passé à la
commande pas rater votre caricature de à
deux balles alger lui avait succédé dans
ses fonctions de se déclarer qu'il était
ministre il n'est responsable de rien
n'est responsable de rien et ce côté pas
parce que vous vous avez donné le kazakh
que tout le monde l'a fait mais je ne
suis pas le seul à avoir quitté le parti
socialiste et je vais me faire c'est pas
l'avoir fait plus tôt peut-être surtout
les tricheurs du service à beaucoup de
monde oui bien sûr écoutez c'est parce
que j'ai dit en parlant des institutions
je pense avoir eu un discours objectif
est le plus neutre possible donc il faut
écouter il faut apprendre aussi à
écouter
j'ai pas fait l'ena mais je sais aussi
écouter donc après ce qu'il verra pour
l'achat
yates a pas écoutés non mais qui parfois
nous gouvernent oui mais vous vous savez
par contre très bien interrompre et ne
pas écouter
allez on sort de votre face à face n'a
pas bien on est sur les réformes
c'est vrai que repartir au combat sur
une réforme des retraites qui touche
tout le monde qui a toujours crisper les
français quel que soit celui qu'elle
apporte
après le mouvement des dg les jaunes on
peut se dire c'est risqué et pourquoi le
fait-il sachant qu'il était déjà voilà
très très très là l'objet de
d'insatisfaction écoutez si si si je
résume donc forcément caricaturant
l'image que l'opinion a eu de tout d'eau
dernier président de la république sous
chirac les gens nous disaient ah nous
sondeurs où est il
y at il un pilote dans l'avion on est
passé à sarkozy et les gens nous
disaient grosso modo à la maintenant on
est sûr qu'il ya un pilote dans l'avion
mais ce qui séduit veut ça n'arrête
l'avion n'arrête pas d'aller dans des
temps différents sens on est passé à
olemps qui a eu un doute sur le fait
qu'il y avait un pilote et même un avion
est maintenant et maintenant et
maintenant avec emmanuel matri ils font
ces gens lui disent grosso modo et on
essaie en clair c'est clair qu'il ya un
pilote dans l'avion mais il semble avoir
oublié qu'à des passagers et du coup
voilà le problème c'est au coeur de ce
débat sur les retraites
moi ça n'intéressera personne que je
dise que moi je crois que c'est plutôt
une réforme de justice sociale cette
affaire de retraite et c'est un paradoxe
inouïe de voir les catégories populaires
plutôt contre aujourd'hui alors que
c'est censé être fait pour elle je crois
que l'essentiel du problème aujourd'hui
c'est qu'ils ne savent pas ce qu'il ya
dans exactement ce qui les menace ou ce
qui les attend avec 7 9 à 12 euros
l'aco les gens sont les mecs c'est pas
tout le monde c'est pas tellement là la
valeur
c'est pas l'heure du point que moi j'ai
tout le temps c'est qu'est ce que ma
catégorie deviendra moi qu'est-ce que je
deviens donc c'est vraiment le problème
on fait pour mettre les citoyens dans le
doubs y compris dans le coût des
réformes commencent à vous avez vraiment
raté quelque chose et même au delà
boris valent au delà évoqué en termes
que peu aimable mais il ya là plus de la
moitié de mes collègues qui n'avaient
jamais fait de politique
moi j'ai un défaut j'en fais depuis 25
ans j'ai été maire pendant plus de 15
ans je sais ce que c'est que de faire
attention à ce que des gens peuvent
considérer des décisions qu'on peut être
amené à prendre parfois à écouter
parfois à reculer parfois aussi à
prendre en compte ce qui peut être dit
parce que vous êtes confrontés dans le
quotidien alors au réel maintenant
collectivement quand on a été élu en
juin 2017 on s'est cru les rois du monde
je le dis sans problème et on a pendant
plusieurs mois dérouler un programme
avec une force qui était celle du
numéraire dans l'hémicycle sans
peut-être être attentif à ce qui pouvait
être dit oui je le dis sans cesse la
question c'est pour commencer il ya eu
les 18 mois de le voir et quand vous
regardez bien la réforme des retraites
le débat il se cristallise en juillet
lorsqu'il ya une dissonance internes à
la majorité sur le recul de l'âge à la
retraite ou sur la longueur de
cotisation ou sur la question de l'âge
pivot qu est déjà sur la table sans être
cité
c'est là où ça part dans tous les sens
parce que vous avez un député de la
majorité qui dit on s'est cru les rois
du monde ce qu'est cette question de
l'arrogance de la suffisance qu elles
soient majoritaires ou qu'elle soit et
vous avez tous les deux écrit là-dessus
porté par la personne même du chef de
l'état c'est ça profond le le péché
originel
oui bien sûr il ya eu une brise mais
c'est pas la première fois en 1980 un
groupe qui a vu la vague rose socialiste
on avait ce mélange à la fois d'une
expérience des landes à laon et parfois
en effet d'excès de vitesse mais qui n'a
encore ça a une vertu c'est que les
camps qui sont dans ce cas là est bien
dans cet élan là ils font leurs efforts
mais ils vont vite alors que tant
d'autres présidents peut-être trop
expérimenté ou tonnes trop de majorité
trop trop confortable et là depuis trop
longtemps vont freiner pour pas prendre
de risque restait populaire et
finalement ne change pas le pays
moi j'aimerais faire qu'on change un
pays parce que le monde va vite et puis
ça secoue l affaire des passagers de
l'avion parce que bien sûr le début mai
les retraites
on en parle depuis le livre blanc de
rocard en 90 91 et on a eu que des
majorités qu'ils n'osaient pas aller au
bout ou kia
mais qui reculaient parce que ça passait
pas juppé à recullé raffarin fillon fait
le minimum
sarkozy a remis ça sur la table et puis
il a transigé sur certain âge marisol
touraine a fait une réforme courageuse
aussi mais avec un étalement prudent
dans le temps hélas cette majorité pas
fait une réforme qu'elle est structurel
c'est à dire que le système de 45 fait
pour beaucoup d'actifs et peu de
personnes âgées ne peut plus continuer
alors qu'on a moins d'actifs et beaucoup
de personnes âgées
donc faut changer la nature mais le
régime est passé aux questions de
calendrier quand même parce qu'à un
socialiste est elle toujours socialiste
arnaud montebourg oui je cours il est
toujours taquin de que je voue une
confiance et c'est très clairement donné
un petit coup de deux tremplins de pouce
à marine le pen
vous voyez des choses comme ça c'est
caricatural mais la lie le problème avec
cette réforme des retraites et que non
seulement vous disiez tout à l'heure les
français ne savent pas où l'exécutif 20
mais il est vraisemblable que le
gouvernement ne le sait pas non plus si
nous nous présenterait pas une réforme
qui est un texte à trous avec un tiers
des articles qui renvoie des ordonnances
sur des sujets qui sont majeurs des
conditions perdition d'un régime on n'en
sait rien non plus et c'est bien ça qui
est inquiétant veux moi je suis pas pour
la réforme pour la réforme faut que ce
soit des réformes de progrès moi je suis
où je serais bien incapable de dire ça
être une réforme de progrès j'ai
beaucoup de motifs de doute sur les
carrières longues la prise en compte de
la pénibilité sur les carrières des
femmes sur les carrières hachées par
n'ont rassuré sur la réforme de la cfdt
c'est la réforme de monsieur edouard
philippe quesne droit d'endroits on est
bon on a fait de tout débat sur les
retraites
je voudrais quand même d'accord on fait
revenir à la question de la violence
même si j'ai l'impression que vous ne
serez pas forcément d'accord avec le
diagnostic du président c'était lors de
ses voeux à la presse
il ya quelque chose il y à une violence
de rue qui s'est installée dans notre
pays il nous faut évidemment non
seulement la réprimer la combattre avec
beaucoup de clarté la sanctionner à
chaque fois qu'elle existe et je serai
intraitable sur le sujet il nous faut
aussi en comprendre les prémices et ça
c'est un travail politique morale sur
notre propre pays consiste à comprendre
comment un tel n'est l'isthme saisir
certains de nos concitoyens et la
dilution en quelque sorte de
tous les rapports auraient loué l'ordre
des choses rock'n'roll et parle d'un
nihilisme une volonté de renverser la
table c'est pas exactement ce que vous
dites autour de ce plateau en fait pour
lui il ya un cran supplémentaire
il ya un rien à [__] in qui est à
l'oeuvre au nihilisme
il n'est pas le premier président à se
servir de chevaux je crois que quand on
est à l'elysée on a le sentiment qu'on
essaye de bien faire et que forcément
tous ces gens qui n'arrêtent pas de
procès de 2,2 de faire des processions
discuter de faire des manifs c'est un
peu insupportable et ingérable qu'est ce
que c'est que ce pays
on en est encore une fois pas là mais
c'est vrai que quand ils exagèrent
oui ils exagèrent évidemment mais c'est
évident qu'il ya verbalement montée du
débat de l'invectivé et surtout de 2,2
de la non croyance dans la province du
pouvoir tel qu'il soit quand j'ai des
viandes gauche toujours je ne te crois
pas je demande à vérifier la défiance
est lui demanda vérifiable moi je sais
le rejet de tous ceux qui n'ont se
maitiennent une forme d'autorité c'est
aussi de la part de tout un chacun
réseaux sociaux info continue le
sentiment de pouvoir te mettre en
situation de décider aussi mais
justement tout à l'heure vous parlez une
compagnie aérienne est ce que vous ne
croyez pas qu'une partie du problème
vient du fait que les passagers sont
actionnaires de la compagnie aérienne
france et les passagers ils ont envie de
se faire entendre moi je suis frappé
tout à l'heure christophe vous disiez
que les français avaient envie d'être
cajoler moi j'ai quand même l'impression
qu'il donne surtout envie de s'exprimer
et d'être entendue je vous rappelle
quand même que pendant les gilet jaune
il y avait une revendication celle du
référendum d'initiative citoyenne
on peut en penser ce qu'il veut ce qu'on
veut mais elle voulait quand même dire
quelque chose
donc pourquoi ça a disparu est ce que ça
ne permettrait pas un petit peu de
diminuer le niveau de violence de donner
plus souvent la parole aux français eric
oui j'avais compris mais moi quand un
français sur deux ne va pas voter depuis
20 ans je m'interroge sur l'opportunité
de faire un référendum tous les
week-ends sauf que ce type de vin en ce
moment ils nous ont la dit quelles
questions poser au ce débat là on l'a eu
à plusieurs endroits quelle question
pose quelles modalités etc
lundi qu'il n'excluait il était sur la
longueur d'année sur mon but je réponds
théorique le répondait au laurie comme
revendication est la triste qu'après le
président effectivement à n'a pas écarté
l'hypothèse de se mettre d'accord avec
moi quand même mais j'ai pas peur du
suffrage universel mais je suis pas un
problème mais vous reconnaissez que pour
résoudre cette crise démocratique
il faudra aller vers mais quelque chose
comme quoi plus d'associations du
citoyen à la décision publique
oui selon des modalités à définir bien
que le citoyen sont pleinement acteur et
pas simplement dans la revendication le
cd voyez enfin je suis toujours frappé
de voir ceci peu de participation au
scrutin et je pense qu'il faut aussi le
prendre en compte dans la proche de tout
un chacun sur les questions politiques
publiques et et aussi de citoyenneté
dans leur ensemble
oui ça fait plus frais plus quand même
c'est vrai pour une demande de
participation et la décision sur des
sujets qui vous concerne et d'un cancer
de votre famille ou de contrôle sur lui
c'est pas seulement la cinquième
république qui est fatigué c'est la
démocratie représentative
elle a de grands mérites elle est
irremplaçable mais seule elle ne
fonctionne plus il faut en effet trouver
des instruments
alors moi je crois y compris le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne est
aussi désigné des choses au niveau local
au niveau régional au niveau européen
tous les niveaux à la qui permettent de
mettre les gens dans le coup de la
nécessaire d'entendre quand même cette
embardée puis je vous donne ma parole
dressa et des députés qui disent on ne
suffit plus sur la démocratie
représentative a suffi les français ont
l'impression que la démocratie
représentative et les passes et elle est
dominée par le haut les gaffes à qui
s'assoient sur les délibérations
parlementaires et qui font leur beurre
ailleurs et puis elle est dépassée par
le bas c'est à dire que vous mettez 40
copains
avec des cabanes sur un aéroport et puis
vous bloquer les décisions d'un conseil
général validé par la justice et même
validée par un référendum régional une
représentation des opinions qui ne s'y
retrouve pas en fait si vous souhaitez
bien supérieur mélenchon à marine le pen
premier parti de france n'est plus
capable de créer un groupe à l'assemblée
nationale au scrutin et ses modes de
scrutin très les excluant ils ont permis
les occasions
cette manière là les gens sont pas
représentés à l'assemblée et oui mais si
la proportionnelle à 100% ce délire
grave que l'exacte e mandat
promotionnelle pu réparé décision donc
il faut entre l'efficacité et la
représentativité nous toujours balancé
la quatrième république
elle est trop peu valables les occasions
je la prépare la cinquième est allé trop
et chaque l'efficacité pour terminer ce
des barbares garder un petit peu du côté
de nos voisins européens ce que la
violence est spécifique à la france
eh bien non mais rien mais ne l'est pas
et quand on regarde on s'aperçoit qu'il
y a toujours un moteur à la violence
politique et notamment la violence dans
la rue c'est la polarisation c'est au
moment où des sociétés sont très
polarisée qu'effectivement les
manifestants ont tendance à dérailler il
ya un exemple raison qu'on oublie
maintenant c'est la campagne pour le
brésil il ya quand même eu une député
assassiné au royaume uni lors de la
campagne pour le brésil dans un contexte
d'extrêmes polarisation vous vous
souvenez maintenant on a tendance à
refermer la parenthèse
mais revenons à des événements
antérieurs en europe il y avait eu un
événement c'est le sommet de gênes en
italie on dit beaucoup clé la police
française se livrent à des violences à
gênes en italie on était en 2001 il y
avait eu des manifestations de masse il
y avait eu un mort la police avait tiré
qui était à l'époque à la tête du pays
s'étaient berlusconi a là encore une
fois un président du conseil qui
polarise et énormément l'opinion on
retrouve la même chose alors dans un
contexte différent toujours g7 à rostock
en allemagne en 2007
et là on retrouve une tradition
allemande de violence qu'on attend ça
ignoré en france représente l'allemagne
toujours comme le pays du dialogue
social
n'oubliez pas que les militants
antinucléaires allemands ont été très
violents et que la police allemande est
souvent très violente on dit en france
que les policiers doivent aller au
contact
en allemagne ils font ça depuis
longtemps et les manifestants entre
manifestants et policiers c'est souvent
des scènes de guerre de rue extrêmement
délicate et enfin il y avait cet
événement fondateur ne l'oublions pas
c'est 1999 vous souvenez l'om c'est à
seattle aux états
ce n'était pas encore de la halle trump
qui était président mais déjà c'était la
contestation de la mondialisation
c'était des scènes où on avait vu la
violence s'installer dans la rue c'était
la première fois qu'on voyait les
magasins fermés avec des grandes
planches en contreplaqué lors de ventes
eurent donc autrement dit la france n'a
pas le monopole de la violence mais elle
a le monopole d'une certaine violence
c'est celle des syndicats d'un
syndicalisme révolutionnaire parce que
ça dans d'autres pays européens ça
n'existe pas la même culte en d'autres
pays européens un syndicat c'est fait
pour négocier pour trouver des consensus
avec le pouvoir merci merci infiniment
on parle un petit peu de votre livre si
vous tous vous dire je vous libère dans
dans un instant macro sous les masques
alors est intéressant c'est de qui le
président est-il le fils sur le bandeau
vous laisser quelques pistes jusqu'à are
clemenceau caligula y beaucoup d'autres
pistes pourquoi il n'ya pas bonaparte
gts que c'est faux on a beaucoup comparé
à bonaparte au début en disant regardez
la lan la jeunesse puis ce côté un peu
autoritaire
je pense que c'est faux bonaparte n'a
pas été élu il a fait un coup d'état
c'est pas le cas de macron si on doit le
comparer c'est peut-être à l'autre
bonaparte louis napoléon bonaparte élu
comme lui à 40 ans au premier président
de la république il a fait le coup
d'état après oui c'est ça il est aussi à
faire que d'aller ensuite bonaparte est
quelqu'un qui à travers son action
militaire veut construire une europe par
la force c'est pas le cas de macron
macron à une vision de l'europe ils
essayent de convaincre ses partenaires
de relancer quelque chose mais pas en
envoyant l'armée française on n'est pas
dans la même comparaison et même son
action interne
regardez comme napoléon bonaparte a
construit les départements a construit
les territoires avec une vision très
centralisé très préfectoral et comment
macron par rapport à cela n'est pas dans
la tradition avoué s'est fâché avec les
territoires avec le local et en même
temps on n'a pas l'impression que sa
centralisation est une centralisation de
préfet plutôt une certaine alisation de
technocrates faut dire aussi que les
moyens sont plus modernes
donc je pense que la comparaison a été
trop rapide et impertinent et de cerner
votre votre enquête généalogique parce
que vous expliquer très bien que si
macron veut avoir une chance il ne sera
pas réélu sur son bilan sur ses réformes
mais au fond s'il est capable de bâtir
une figure de construire une forme de
personnages bref de s'inscrire dans une
filiation et là vous allez du côté de la
politique de l'histoire du roman et même
de la mythologie en même temps quand on
vous dit on a l'impression que c'est
jamais la bonne piste c'est à dire qu'il
n'est
mais le fils ni de caligula ni de brut
us ni même d'un dead france ou d'un
rocard il ne serait le fils de personne
il a une paternité multiples sans doute
mais il est le fils parfait de personnes
je pense que d'euros car il il a pris
certains abîmé rocard serait terrifiée
et devoirs macron maltraiter les
syndicats par exemple je pense qu'il est
assez proche de tiers des deux tiers si
j'ose dire celui qui a servi louis
philippe hui celui qui a quand même
installé là la troisième république
il est évidemment saint simoniens en
économie mais il a aussi quelque chose
de schumpeter et il est attentif à ce
que disent aujourd'hui les économistes
comme amartya sen c'est très très
complexe et racines historiques de mains
il a raison il faut se construire de
manière extrêmement protéiforme mosaïque
pour correspondre à une moderne
personnage de roman du côté de l ouïe du
côté du romanaise je pense que le
premier macron était était évidemment
stendhalien je pense qu'aujourd'hui il
évolue et que c'est pas du côté de
stendhal qu'on trouvera le prochain mac
row celui qui complète bien peut-être
j'aurais tendance à aller dans deux
directions si il veut embrasser le plus
la france et n'oublier personne y
compris la france populaire faut qu'il
aille un peu vers balzac
en revanche s'il correspond aux gens un
peu n'ont peut-être pas rastignac plutôt
une des figures plus plus plus
consensuel peut-être le père goriot par
un peu plus pompidolien peut plus partir
analystes mais attention aujourd'hui le
penchant ne serait ce que pour des
raisons électorales l'emmène plutôt vers
quelque chose qui est plus à droite on
va être plus près de mauriac
peut-être que de que de balzac donc il
faudra faire attention avec ces
filiations le littéraire là parce
qu'elles peuvent emmener dans des
directions il ya une scène aussi à la
fin de votre livre dans laquelle vous
raconter que emmanuel macron étant
panthéon
sous la nef est là pour bien comprendre
l'ampleur de la mégalomanie du
personnage si je puis me permettre
ils demandent où ils s'autorisent à
toucher et à changer le cadran du
pendule de foucault le voir que la même
voilà voilà
le pendule de foucault c'est ce qui
prouve que la terre tourne en quelque
sorte est donc lancé ce pan du l'immense
inquiet qui balancent duo de la nef du
panthéon c'est un geste extrêmement
symbolique s'est un peu comme mettre en
marche le monde
à l'aube des temps et il s'offre ce ce
petit plaisir et donc on voit bien que à
ce moment là il a une
comme quand il est allé à la basilique
de saint denis après sa déclaration de
candidature
il a une volonté de se mettre dans une
perspective historique et avait
d'ailleurs visité le panthéon plusieurs
reprises avant la cérémonie pour pour
simone veil en préparation de celle pour
maurice genevoix il a été frappé de voir
que il y avait les écrivains la guerre
de 14 qui avait très peu de présidents
de la république ceux qui ont été
assassinés et donc que la figure
politique était arrêté un peu aux portes
de ce panthéon il ya une vision de
l'histoire chez cet homme dans quelle
histoire il s'inscrit sans doute la
vision la plus imprégné que l'on est
depuis mitterrand qui lui aussi
d'ailleurs était allée sur les gisants
de la basilique saint denis quand il
avait dû pour une émission de télévision
alors qu'il rapport il incarnait la
gauche de choisir le lieu qui
représentait la france droite francs il
ya aussi du mitterrand alors il y a
beaucoup de filiation même s'il n'est
pas forcément le fils du d'un seul
personnage est ce qu il peut aussi
transmettre c'est à dire est ce qu'il
est aussi un peu dans cette volonté être
que le maquereau nisme survivra à
maquereau pour l'instant non honteux on
peut dire que à coup sûr si mac on
disait aujourd'hui j'en ai marre je m'en
vais y aurait pas d'héritier du
maquereau nisme alors imaginons qu'il
soit réélu en 2022 nous sommes en 2027
dans l'obligation d'avoir un autre
candidat pour le maquereau qui se sera
on est ce qu'on a l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui edouard philippe pourrait
reprendre le flambeau non il correspond
à une partie de l'anachronisme
est-ce que c'est christophe castaner ou
richard ferrand où des députés non on a
l'impression que le maquereau nice met
un moment de l'histoire en ce moment si
particulier
si un palpable qu'on lui voit pas une
postérité
mais c'est à lui aussi d' d'inventer
cela monsieur l'a dit tout à l'heure
c'est deux en deux ans tout s'est fait
donc tout peut aller très vite
on ne sait pas où on sera je dirais en
2022 comme en 2027 appel macron sous les
masques aux édition de l'observatoire
vous restez avec nous christophe barbier
je rappelle aussi que vous êtes
comédiens on n'a pas le temps d'en
parler vous jouer tous les soirs non
pour jouer quoi une fois par semaine
plusieurs fois dont joue le lundi 1
seule enseigne sur l'histoire du théâtre
et de la politique puisque théâtre et
politique en france ça va ensemble et
puis les autres soirs de la semaine
choses vues de victor hugo tout ça au
théâtre de préimpression toutes ces
figures du passé vous vous passionnez de
france made in us vous rendez victor
hugo dit les ministres sont comme des
carreaux de vitre on voit le président à
travers 10 en 1850 mai
c'est toujours vrai aujourd'hui allez on
va accueillir à présent l'europe titre h
esquire le nouveau moto mais monsieur
retraites du gouvernement
à l'heure où on le comprend on le redit
la mobilisation prend un tournant
radical
on l'accueille tout de suite juste après
ce sujet sujet sur le durcissement du
conflit
c'est me ahmed tazir merci à tous
microphone en renfort une quinzaine de
militants de la cgt envahissent le hall
du siège de la cfdt
vendredi dernier un des salariés est
prise à partie et on ira jusqu'au
retrait scandent les cgpi des militants
désireux de faire la leçon aux camarades
cfdt qu'ils jugent mou dans l'opposition
à la réforme des retraites
l'opération est parfois violentes à
l'extérieur des altercations avec les
forces de l'ordre
une opération coup de poing condamnée
par le patron de la cfdt qui porte
plainte
ça suffit vendredi dernier une intrusion
avec des crachats des violences verbales
et physiques des insultes ce matin une
intrusion dans nos locaux depuis quinze
personnes cagoulées qui coupent
l'électricité
en tout cas je trouve que ce climat est
insupportable alors que sur les rails en
france et dans le métro à paris les
transports deviennent fluide
le syndicat de philippe martinez tente
des barouds d'honneur
ici une intrusion dans un syndicat mais
aussi des appels à couper l'électricité
à l'elysée à la cgt cheminots de paris
on en est convaincu il y as besoin de
faire évoluer cette grève avec des
actions coup de poing la avoir des temps
forts régulier pour pour faire vivre
cette grève
avec aussi des actions coup de poing un
comme on les appelle pour pour montrer
que on lâche pas ce gouvernement et
surtout la grève est tout sauf fini les
actions coup de poing et ben c'est par
exemple aller voir les députés de la
république en marche qui refuse de nous
recevoir et aller les voir lorsqu'ils
font des leurs voeux c'est par exemple
aller au théâtre
voilà où se trouvait macron il a dit
venez me chercher on vient le chercher
on vient discuter avec lui pour
malheureusement il est parti mais voilà
c'est ce genre d'action parce
qu'aujourd'hui ce gouvernement
malheureusement il comprend que le
rapport de force
voilà à l'assemblée nationale le premier
ministre condamne fermement ces actions
coup de poing vouloir bloquer un certain
nombre de sites
ne pas respecter la loi en
s'introduisant dans telle ou telle
enceinte privée procéder à des coupures
sauvages de courant tout cela tout cela
c'est méconnaître la démocratie tout
cela c'est méconnaître la loi et tout
cela doit être sanctionné car ce n'est
pas acceptable
ce n'est pas acceptable monsieur le
député vous le savez parfaitement et le
rapport de force pourrait se durcir
la cgt et fo et solidaires ces syndicats
fer de lance de la contestation
promettent une remobilisation pour
vendredi prochain jour de l'adoption du
projet de réforme des retraites en
conseil des ministres bonsoir leurs
emplettes rachète skype
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes le
nouveau secrétaire d'état chargé de
cette réforme des retraites nouvelles
coupures d'électricité sauvage dans le
val-de-marne la cgt énergie explique
qu'au fond ça n'est pas la fin du monde
que de couper le courant que répondez
vous mais c'est inacceptable c'est
inacceptable enfin il faut quand même
qu'on revienne à la raison
tranquillement qu'il y ait des débats
dans un pays démocratique comme le nôtre
où chacun peut s'exprimer c'est très
bien qu'il y ait un droit de grève
qu'ils soient protégés
c'est très bien un droit de manifester
c'est très bien mais on ne peut pas
accepter comme ça qu'on décide pour
faire valoir ses idées et de couper
l'électricité qui d'interrompre une
manifestation culturelle qui d'envahir
un local privé non c'est comme écouter
en tout cas la justice aura à faire son
travail
et moi je pense que à chaque fois que
c'est nécessaire il faut porter plainte
mais détenus concrètement comment vous
allez réussir là d'une certaine façon à
retrouver l'apaisement
comment vous faites cesser ses actions
on a vu on en a parlé avant le climat
social est très dégradée jeu si vous
permettez moi je vais essayer de vous
faire partager mon analyse sur quoi mon
analyse se repose sur ce que je vois
dans ma circonscription j'étais au 20e à
ennetières-en-weppes d'une petite petit
village ma circonscription samedi soir
pas jouir
il y avait plus d'un quart de la
population y ait plus de 300 personnes
qui étaient déjà beaucoup de députés qui
n'ont pas pu faire leurs voeux
ou dont les verts ont été chahutées oui
j'entends c'est ce que j'ai d'ailleurs
je vous ai dit docteur c'est
inacceptable moi j'étais aux voeux du
maire il y avait d'autres élus qui
étaient là j ai été bien accueilli et
d'ailleurs on a pu aussi discuter avec
les citoyens qui étaient là lorsqu'on a
pris le verre de l'amitié
mais je voulais vous parler de cela
moins de 2 des échanges que j'ai eus
avec les citoyens qui étaient là qu'est
ce qu'ils m'ont dit retraités d'ailleurs
pour certains ou jeunes actifs pour
d'autres mais ils m'ont dit monsieur
députés ça doit être très différent ce
que vous vivez à paris alors il m'a
peut-être jour monsieur le député fait
rien je suis leur député sur le fond ils
ont raison aussi de rappeler que leurs
députés
ça doit différence que vous vivez à
paris que de ce que nous on vit mais on
voit là ils comprennent bien que c'est
pas tout à fait la même chose locaux
bien sûr les transports locaux ici pour
les franciliens c'est très difficile
c'est compliqué ça va mieux ça va mieux
depuis le début de la semaine et je
crois qu'il faut regarder la réalité des
territoires la réalité de notre pays
alors si la cgt ne cautionne pas c'est
le terme ces actions ces coupures
d'électricité et philippe martin aide
condamne à titre personnel est-ce que
c'est suffisant
votre avis comme réaction écoutez moi je
n'ai pas forcément envie de commenter
les déclarations de philippe martinez je
respecte le leader d'un grand syndicat
français la cgt
moi je crois que grands syndicats
français s'inscrit dans les règles
républicaines donc qui condamne le fait
qu'on coupe le courant à jeu j'entends
bien je pense qu'il faut qu'il le fasse
avec énergie et avec force et que cette
condamnation
et bien tout le monde doit l'entendre y
compris peut être ce qu'ils ont réalisé
si jamais il devait se réclamer de son
syndicat barbier la nouveauté c'est pas
si fréquent c'est que deux syndicats se
font un peu la guerre aujourd'hui en
tout cas il ya beaucoup de tension entre
la cgt pas toute une partie cgt énergie
et la cfdt avec ses deux intrusions
subie par par la centrale ces quelques
ces derniers jours comment vous voyez
cet ancien est ce que quand le front
syndical est à ce point fissurer
quand les syndicats trop la guerre est
ce que
c'est bon pour le gouvernement non non
pas forcément il faut garder des
interlocuteurs stable pour pouvoir
dialoguer on a un double mouvement de
cannibalisme on à la basse qui n'obéit
plus aux chefs
on le voit avec les branches de la cgt
qui font ces actions et puis on a une
guerre entre les modérés et les plus
radicaux et donc c'est pas bon donc il
faut que le gouvernement à un moment
donné aide le syndicalisme à retomber
sur ses pattes
peut-être en ouvrant une grande
conférence salariale
on a un problème salarial dans ce pays
le travail coûte à la fois cher pour les
entreprises qui vont être compétitive
il rapporte pas assez aux salariés on
l'a vu avec les enseignants quand on la
touche aux retraites s'est posé tout de
suite le problème salarial est ce qu'il
faudrait pas ouvrir une grande
conférence salariale pour faire monter
le pouvoir d'achat de tous les français
sans pénaliser les entreprises et les
employeurs à écouter des gens on peut se
dire surviennent juste objectifs vont
les choses c'est que le pouvoir d'achat
en 2019 a progressé significativement
plus de 2% 2,3 pour cent je le fais
mémoire et que ça montre bien que
l'action qui est mise en place par le
gouvernement et la majorité depuis plus
de deux ans porte ses fruits
ça veut dire aussi que les choix qui ont
été faits à l'issue de la crise sociale
notamment de permettre une meilleure
valorisation du travail au travers d'une
dynamisation de la prime d'activité
porte ses fruits c'est à dire que les
choix que nous avons fait de
redistribution parce que sur le fond
c'est un petit peu ce que vous dites de
redistribution mais aussi de
valorisation du travail sont des bons
choix qui fonctionne qui alimente
d'ailleurs sur le fond aussi notre
croissance car même si elle n'est pas
tout à fait à ce qu'on voudrait elle se
maintient quand même dans un contexte
qui n'est pas facile on a l'impression à
vous entendre que tout va bien peu au
fond le pouvoir d'achat s'améliore on a
entendu d'autres chiffres les
l'investissement mais on a quand même
ce mouvement de grève qui est le plus
long de l'histoire des conflits sociaux
ça ne vous inquiète pas de voir la
manière dont il se transforme mais moi
je distingue deux choses l'un
le climat social qui est une réalité je
vous faisais tout à leurs références à
ce que j'entends dans ma circonscription
les entreprises aussi que je peux
visiter ou ceux que je rencontre je ne
peut être acceptée ce spectacle de haine
en france des scènes de violence qui
détruisent la france signé nicolas
sarkozy vient je crois que l'ancien
président de la république a souhaité
d'ailleurs s'exprimer dans je crois
l'orientation son discours c'est plutôt
une rotation de concorde il a cherché à
montrer l'importance qu'il ya dans notre
pays à réussir le vivre ensemble
je crois qu'il a raison d'ailleurs de le
faire ce que je voulais vous dire merci
à manca ouais c'est que oui il y a eu un
mouvement de grève qui d'ailleurs peut
continuer encore aujourd'hui mais on
voit bien quand même que la tendance est
à la reprise
donc je ne vous dis pas que tout va bien
on voit bien que la tendance est à la
reprise on voit bien aussi que sur le
fond ceux qui avaient des inquiétudes
dans les régimes spéciaux qui ont été
entendus il avait déjà été entendue dès
la mi décembre puisque sous la conduite
de jean baptiste jabbari et directions
des deux entreprises ratp et sncf ont
fait de vraies propositions qu'ils
peuvent faire autrement je crois tout
simplement parce qu'ils ont l'impression
d'avoir écouté je chante ans est votre
analyse peut-être avez-vous on peut
aussi poser le fait qu'il ya eu un
travail de concertation qui a été fait
est que il a abouti sur des propositions
question si mauvaise que ça pour les
salariés on est bien un travail de
concertation avec deux syndicat
réformiste la cfdt et l'unsa ici à
l'assemblée nationale tollé de
l'opposition qui concept qui consiste à
dire vous nous faites signer un chèque
en blanc
on va avoir un texte à trous comment
vous pouvez nous demander d'examiner et
de voter un texte sans trancher sur son
financement
qu'est ce que vous répondez bon je crois
que ce qui vous dit ça je ne m'en fais
pas grief mais peut être peut être
peut-être aussi sur une posture mais je
ne vais pas vous répondre que sur ce
sujet nous confirmait bien que cette
question essentielle du financement
après la conférence syndicale est
décidée par ordonnances sont pas les
députés qui vont à contre coeur bat et
si c'est le principe de le principe de
l'ordonnancé que les élus des députés
donne une habilitation au gouvernement
c'est habité souhaitent précise c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que le gouvernement
l'a demandé de façon précise en
décrivant les i dames sur lequel il
serait
habilité cette habilitation va permettre
une chose d'ailleurs que j'appelle de
mes voeux c'est que l'accord que je
souhaite qui sera sortira de la
conférence du financement puisse être
entièrement écrit dans cette ordonnance
de manière à ce qu'ils soient appliqués
donc on peut pas à la fois lorsqu'on est
dans l'opposition
en tous les cas une certaine opposition
vous dire laisser de la place au
dialogue social favorisé la démocratie
sociale et lorsque nous prenons des
mesures qui visent à donner toute sa
place à la démocratie sociale vous dire
avait sur le fond c'est pas bien il faut
qu'on choisisse entre les parlements le
parlement n'est pas maltraité
non vous savez des ordonnances je suis
bien placé pour en avoir vécu mais aussi
comme rapporteur pendant les deux années
et demi de mandat de député que j'ai
réalisé les ordonnances c'est un temps
pour débattre du domaine d'habilitation
du gouvernement et ensuite un temps pour
débattre de la ratification donc très
franchement objectivement objectivement
on ne peut pas dire quand on est dans
l'opposition qu'on est mal traitée par
les ordonnances
on peut dire c'est une autre façon de
faire la loi mais on doit reconnaître
parce que c'est vrai que nous voyons
deux fois deux fois le texte une fois
une habilitation une fois aux
ratifications il n'y a pas besoin
d'avoir fait de longues études en droit
constitutionnel pour voir cela bon on va
parler des avocats puisque ils ont
décidé de reconduire au mois sept
semaines alors leur mouvement de grève
où en sont les négociations bien il y à
des réunions techniques des réunions
techniques qui ailleurs qui avait lieu
hier qu'ils vont continuer cette semaine
il y a la volonté cette semaine à la
fois je l'espère de la part des avocats
mais aussi de la part de gouvernements
de continuer à s'expliquer car le sujet
leur cotisation alors que leur caisse
est très bien gérée de façon autonome et
les bénéficiaires mais le débat il est
très simple les avocats ou une caisse
autonome mais comme d'autres comme les
notaires ils ont une caisse autonome qui
comme en équilibre un système par
répartition pas entre les cotisations
des pensions et l'âge à laquelle la
retraite est prise il n'y a pas d'autre
façon de faire
ils ont beaucoup de cotisation parce que
ils ont beaucoup entre guillemets
daveran démographique qui est favorable
donc c'est dire qu'ils ont beaucoup plus
d'actifs que de retraités
mais sauf à imaginer qu'il va y avoir
une progression exponentielle du nombre
d'avocats qui justifiera en permanence
déséquilibre très favorable
démographique et il y aura un moment où
ça ne sera pas le cas et le cor conseil
d'orientation des retraites j'ai siégé
pour représenter l'assemblée nationale
sur la base des informations transmises
par la caisse des avocats a établi qu
autour de 2040 2045 la situation
d'ailleurs ce sont les choses c'est que
la réalité de demain de la caisse des
avocats n'est pas la réalité
d'aujourd'hui et le gouvernement dans
son ouverture le radis mais comme on l'a
dit avec les pilotes de ligne si vous
voulez maintenir un dispositif
supplémentaire supplémentaires on est
d'abord dans le régime universel avec
des cotisations que qui sont
supplémentaires et que vous voulez créer
une dynamique parce qu'ils y sont
attachés de péréquation qui fasse que
les plus hauts revenus dans la
profession d'avocat donne un minimum de
pension plus favorables ou plus petit on
leur a dit c'est possible on peut voir
et la solidarité dans cette profession
pour terminer monsieur le secrétaire
d'état on entendait alain duhamel dans
un des reportages diffusés un peu plus
tôt demandé une grande séance
d'explication présidentielle sur cette
réforme elle manque pas à la télévision
bien sûr elles manquent pas cette séance
de pédagogie
bah écoutez vous invitez déjà secrétaire
d'état je vous remercie il essaye de
faire là ouvre de pédagogie auprès de
vos téléspectateurs
ça veut dire que autres cas il ya du
travail de pédagogie vous dire que la
pédagogie est l'explication pour une
prise de parole à la fin quand même
c'est un moment démocratique un peu
curieux que nous avons vécu faut que le
président à la fin quand ça sera voté en
fasse acte il a signé des lois devant
les caméras de la promulguer des lois
dans des caméras
il pourrait en faire au moins autant et
peut-être même plus pour cette loi là
quand même bon en tous les cas moi
j'entends que vous
vous veut et ça vous paraît avoir du
sens que le président de la république
s'exprime
moi je souhaitais genton jouffre été
personnellement l'instant je vais vous
dire très clairement le gouvernement est
au travail sous la conduite du premier
ministre
nous étions encore en réunion avec le
premier ministre avec muriel pénicaud
avec olivier dussopt hop avec agnès
buzyn avec tous les ministres qui sont
concernés par cette réforme pour faire
que le sujet que nous allons porter
devant le parlement soit un sujet de
solidarité qui nous permettent de
réussir aux vivants sont même si
beaucoup vous restez avec nous l'europe
7h et skema terminer cette émission
comme tous les soirs avec la chronique
de valérie brochard à nous raconte sa
journée à l'assemblée où est-elle
valérie ce soir je suis juste devant le
bureau de la commission des affaires
européennes de l'assemblée nationale et
je peux vous dire ni rien qu'à
l'intérieur il y a un sacré bazar je
viens vous expliquer pourquoi
[Musique]
bonsoir valérie alors qu'est ce qui se
passe à la commission des affaires
européennes
c'est la guerre c'est la guerre meriem
une guerre fratricide entre deux
marcheurs de spécialistes deux députés
qui réclament tous les deux la
présidence de la commission des affaires
européennes
vous allez voir sur votre gauche
le challenger pierre-alexandre anglade
députés des français de l'étranger et
ancien porte parole de la liste
renaissance aux dernières élections
européennes sur votre droite
l'actuelle présidente de la commission
sabine qu'il est député d'indre-et-loire
qui refuse de céder sa place et oui il
est là le problème
myriam depuis cet été donc à la mi
législature comme l'a promis et richard
ferrand tous les présidents de
commissions se sont engagés à remettre
leur titre en jeu certains ont été
réélus d'autres ont dû céder leur place
seulement voilà sabine refusé de
soumettre sa présidence au vote parce
qu'elle estime que sa commission qui ne
fait pas partie des commissions
permanentes ne doit pas répondre aux
mêmes règles ce matin elle donnait une
conférence de presse pour s'expliquer
j'ai le droit avec moi puisque cette
commission elle n'a pas les mêmes
prérogatives que les autres mais elle a
besoin de la stabilité le poste n'était
pas disponible et le groupe a quand même
ouvert l'élection pour désigner enfin en
interne le candidat c'est pour ça qu'on
est maintenant dans cette situation un
peu ubuesque où il ya un candidat
désigné pour la présidence de cette
commission pour un poste qui n'est pas
disponible puisqu'il faut contrairement
aux commissions permanentes une
démission officielle
eh oui une situation ubuesque puisqu'en
juillet dernier sabine thilay ne s'est
donc pas représenté à son poste
refusant la nouvelle règle du jeu mais
pierre alexandre anglaise lui a bien été
élu pour la remplacer or vous venez de
l'entendre tant que sabine refuse de
démissionner et bien pire avec cendres
ne peut pas précéder ses bisbilles
internes f1 des apps le travail
mission un commissaire qui ne fait à un
jeune du groupe a les roms nous a même
confié je cite le climat est tendu
je n'y vais plus alors cette affaire
dure depuis trop longtemps pour le
groupe majoritaire sabine qui laissera
provoqué demain matin et peut-être même
exclu du groupe o à suivre évidemment
elle pour moi cette vie parlementaire ou
pas d'amour la vie parlementaire
je les ai découvertes y compris les
bisbilles je vais découvrir ses deux
amis c'est passionnant et je suis pas
sûr que même si je comprends la petite
capsule
je suis pas sûr que ça soit
représentatif kwh m2 merci beaucoup
laurent petit rachesky d'être venu sur
le plateau des cp merci à vous
christophe bardet d'être passés nous
voir c'est la fin de cette émission
merci et travail soirée à demain
[Musique]